you look amazing first of all let's talk
about this look because I feel like it's
very appropriate for Vegas and grow
you're having a moment yesterday we saw
you at the woman in the lead panel you
said that you want to join album with
nothing that fashion I let's keep it
going
why not I think it's definitely not more
than ever a lot more unity between women
in the industry and not because we
didn't want to then but I think now the
audience the industry is really
demanding and we're like oh we can do
that you're gonna let us do that okay
for sure and they want more of it I mean
they're eating it up you know but what
some of you said at the panel yesterday
that's Tucker Courtney is that you also
recognize that there's a shift with the
men - they're paying attention and
giving you guys those opportunities as
well I mean just open for bad bunny at
his pump sir what was that experience
like for you what's it like to hit the
road with them although we love the song
so much and we knew it was gonna be a
hit what it did for both of our careers
was I mean monumental for for both of us
and I think that you know him taking
that opportunity to allow me to take the
stage on one of the United worlds or
that's amazing
because you know that's part of the men
taking responsibility and saying hey you
know we want to be a part of this
movement too and it's not about creating
a world where only women exist but about
equality about coexisting all together
for everybody and whatever community you
identify it right and you actually
started okay so you're nominated in the
same category as JLo and we know that
you did your cover yeah Becky from the
block so how does it feel to be in the
same category as your idol I mean it's
so surreal it's so surreal and I think
for me it's a true testament to you know
what it is to continue working continue
staying focused and and and sacrificing
and and just being creative and all
these things because it really has
started to pay off and you know someone
like her who was accomplished so much to
even be in the same category is like I'm
winning already so already warm ya know
I feel very blessed you know what's
amazing about Latin music right now is
everyone wants to get in on the action I
mean just this past week alone right
Madonna Alicia Keys Katy Perry all these
artists want to collaborate with other
Latin artists but I gotta ask you what
would you say is like Wanda climate for
people who want to be an honorary member
of the Latino game people like myself
it's really hard
where I plant my feet you know am i
accepted on this side and my accepted on
the other and I think the biggest thing
is to just be authentic be genuine don't
do anything just because it's hot right
now but because you genuinely want to be
a part of it and that's what I see with
a lot of people and one thing about
Latinos that I do know for a fact is we
love sharing sharing is caring we love
when people embrace our culture and
enjoy it and have fun and so I'm happy
I'm happy that people are you know
Johnny laughs I mean yeah that's why
there's so much food out those parties I
can't forget us at the wedding - Regina
sure and actually you bring up a good
point because you are bilingual so how
is it important for you to be able to
share you know your time and your music
and both English and in Spanish yeah I
talked about butch up power all the time
potent power is my secret super power I
speak at Spanglish a little bit Spanish
a little bit of English I'm not perfect
in either or now because I've literally
been mixing the language for so long but
um yeah I mean I just think it trying to
learn more and more as I go writing in
Spanish watching novellas listening to
more Spanish music all those things real
quick where's your favorite place to
listen to loud music is the car the
cloud or the bedroom
[Music]